Yogi Barra once said 90% of the game is half mental. His quote was more philosophical than accurate, but sport and performance psychologists exist because succeeding at an elite level is not just about athletics. Now, chances are you aren't an Olympian or a professional athlete, but how many times has someone told you to just focus before a big presentation at work, or maybe a big test at school? In this episode, we speak with a psychologist about how the best. best of the best mentally prepare to perform and how psychology is helping them. I'm Audrey Hamilton,
尤吉·贝拉曾说，比赛的90%是心理因素。他的话与其说是准确，不如说是哲学层面的，但运动和表现心理学家的存在，是因为在精英水平上取得成功不仅仅关乎运动能力。现在，你可能不是奥林匹克选手或职业运动员，但在工作中进行重要演讲或在学校参加重要考试前，有多少次有人告诉你“专注点”？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，探讨最顶尖的人才如何在心理上为表现做好准备，以及心理学如何帮助他们。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，
and this is speaking of psychology. Steve Pretanga is a founder of a sport and performance psychology consulting firm called I Performance Consultants. He has consulted with Olympic athletes on the USA track and field team and is now taking his expertise beyond sports as a member of the American Psychological Association's Coalition for Psychology of High Performance. Welcome, Dr. Portanga. Welcome. Thanks for. I think a lot of people have misconceptions about what sports psychologists do. So you are one. So can you tell us more about your work? I'm particularly interested in your work with the USA Track and Field Team. What kind of mental preparation is required to perform at that highest level of sports? I had the distinct pleasure of working with the team in London in 2012 at the last Olympics and thought
这是《心理学谈话》。史蒂夫·波坦加是一家名为“I Performance Consultants”的运动与表现心理咨询公司的创始人。他曾为美国田径队的奥运选手提供咨询，现在作为美国心理学会“高性能心理学联盟”的成员，他正将自己的专业知识扩展到体育之外。欢迎您，波坦加博士。欢迎。谢谢。我认为很多人对运动心理学家所做的工作存在误解。既然您是其中之一，能多谈谈您的工作吗？我对您与美国田径队的工作特别感兴趣。在最高水平的体育竞技中，需要什么样的心理准备？我有幸在2012年伦敦奥运会上与该队合作，当时我以为
that I was incredibly prepared to get into that environment, had a number of mentors that were there. and the environment of living in the village and being at Olympics is absolutely unparalleled. The pressure is absolutely amazing. It would be the equivalent of having everyone in the Super Bowl, all of those teams living together throughout the duration, all of the teams in the NCAA tournament living together. You have over 10,000 athletes in a very small environment. Everyone is required to wear their national team gear, colors, logos all over the place.
我已经为进入那种环境做好了充分的准备，那里有许多导师。住在奥运村并参加奥运会的环境是绝对无与伦比的。压力大得惊人。这相当于让超级碗的所有球队在整个赛季期间住在一起，或者让NCAA锦标赛的所有球队住在一起。你在一个非常小的环境中拥有超过10,000名运动员。每个人都被要求穿上他们的国家队装备，到处都是颜色和标志。
And so there's constant reminder that this is, something different. A big deal, right? Absolutely. Be fascinating to see the amount of money that the City of London spent for signage. The Olympic rings were everywhere throughout the city. I mean, you could not miss at all what was going on. And so the pressure there is really intense, really unique, nonstop. And so to be able to have the athletes and the team and the staff be prepared for that environment was my main job.
所以不断有提醒说，这确实是与众不同的。这是一件大事，对吧？绝对是。看到伦敦市为标牌投入的资金量真是令人着迷。整个城市到处都是奥运五环。我的意思是，你不可能错过正在发生的事情。所以那里的压力非常大，非常独特，而且是持续不断的。因此，能够让运动员、团队和工作人员为那种环境做好准备是我的主要工作。
Was it challenging to get athletes to focus in that kind of an environment? Absolutely. It's really an interesting process where for some sports it's pretty easy to try and have this belief that nothing is different. The 100 meters is 100 meters, whether you're in sixth grade or in the Olympic finals. And yet the energy in that Olympic stadium is absolutely unreal. even being in the stands, you can feel your hair stand on edge. I mean, it's absolutely electric. So you have to be over-prepared to be able to handle that.
让运动员在这种环境中保持专注具有挑战性吗？绝对是。这是一个非常有趣的过程，对于某些运动来说，试图相信“没什么不同”是很容易的。100米就是100米，无论你是在六年级还是在奥运会决赛中。然而，奥林匹克体育场里的能量绝对是不真实的。即使站在看台上，你也能感觉到头发竖起来。我的意思是，这绝对是令人兴奋的。所以你必须做好过度准备，才能应对那种情况。
There's so many different distractions that come up in the process of getting there, but to really be able to execute, you have to take advantage of that energy and know very specifically, very deliberately, what you're going to do with it, how you're going to channel it. Is most of the preparation happening before they even get to London, or is it happening while they're in the Olympic Village or wherever they are during the games? Both. Whenever you're talking about any kind of performance, there's a tremendous amount of preparation
在到达那里的过程中会出现许多不同的干扰，但要真正能够执行，你必须利用那种能量，并非常具体、非常刻意地知道你要用它做什么，以及如何引导它。大部分准备工作是在他们到达伦敦之前进行的，还是在他们住在奥运村或比赛期间的任何地方进行的？两者都有。当你谈论任何形式的表现时，都有大量的准备工作
that has to go into that, to be able to rely on a sense of automaticity. And the more you have that learned, the easier it is to be able to perform in those environments. Being in Denver, I have a fathead of Peyton Manning up on the wall for the high school kids that I work with this quote that says pressure is what you feel when you don't know what the hell you're doing. And I think there's a lot of truth to that. And that applies mentally as much as it does physically. And if we have time to prepare athletes to get to that point, fantastic, one of the interesting things with track and field, though, is we don't have a national team until the plane leaves for whatever national trip we're going on. So in the interim, the athletes are all over
必须投入其中，才能依赖一种自动化的感觉。你学得越多，在这些环境中表现就越容易。在丹佛，我为我辅导的高中生在墙上贴了一张佩顿·曼宁的照片，上面写着：“压力是你不知道自己在做什么时所感受到的东西。”我认为这句话很有道理。这在心理上和身体上同样适用。如果我们有时间让运动员准备好达到那个点，那就太棒了。然而，田径运动有趣的一点是，在飞机起飞前往任何国际比赛之前，我们并没有国家队。因此，在此期间，运动员们分散在
the country with different coaches. Many of them are at university. competing for those teams with those coaches. And so to try and have consistent contact and interaction and work with them up until we get to the point of team travel is incredibly difficult. And there's always a lot of athletes that are, they'll do fantastic until they get to an international team trip, and especially the Olympics. And something unique will happen there. They start putting too much pressure on themselves. They start to have a little chink in their armor that they've never experienced with before. And so being on site to handle that as it comes up is really important as well.
全国各地，由不同的教练指导。他们中的许多人在大学里，为那些球队和教练效力。因此，在我们要进行团队旅行之前，试图与他们保持持续的联系、互动和工作是非常困难的。总是有很多运动员表现得非常出色，直到他们参加国际团队旅行，尤其是奥运会。那里会发生一些独特的事情。他们开始给自己施加太大的压力。他们开始出现以前从未经历过的心理裂痕。因此，在现场处理这些问题也非常重要。
How much do, and you're touching on this a little bit, but I want to keep going a little bit further. I mean, how much do athletes' mental state affect their performance, even at the peak of their careers? I mean, they've been doing this pretty much, I'm sure, at some point, their whole life, right, or more than half their life. Absolutely. It's very interesting. There's a lot of sport psychologists that will go out there and try and put a number on the percentage of whatever sport is mental. And I find that a very interesting approach because I don't know anyone who's gone to the Olympics with a master's or a PhD in sports psychology and gotten a medal. And if the mental side was truly that important, you would see a lot of that representation there.
运动员的心理状态在多大程度上影响他们的表现，即使是在他们职业生涯的巅峰时期？我的意思是，我相信他们几乎一生，或者说大半辈子都在做这件事，对吧？绝对是。这非常有趣。有很多运动心理学家会试图给运动中心理因素的百分比定一个数字。我发现这是一种非常有趣的方法，因为我不知道有谁带着运动心理学的硕士或博士学位去参加奥运会并获得了奖牌。如果心理方面真的那么重要，你会看到很多这样的代表在那里。
In sports and other performance settings, it's physical. If you do not have the ability to get from point A to point B within a certain time, that mental piece is completely irrelevant. Except that the mental is a huge part of this planning and this preparation and developing the physical ability. the skills, the understanding of strategy that go into it. And it's really important to be able to get that out and deliver that consistently. And if you aren't going to be able to perform at your best, to be able to minimize how far off you are. And that is a huge part of it.
在体育和其他表现环境中，它是身体上的。如果你没有能力在一定时间内从A点到达B点，那么心理部分就完全无关紧要了。除非心理是这种规划、准备以及发展身体能力、技能和理解策略的巨大组成部分。能够将其发挥出来并持续交付是非常重要的。如果你不能发挥出最好的水平，能够尽量减少差距也是其中的重要部分。
And that's where every athlete will go through different things in their career, that idea of pressure will change throughout their career. You go through different responsibilities within a team. You know, you're just one of the people on the bench, all of a sudden you're starter, now you're the team captain, now you're the person expected to carry the team. You're going to your first Olympics, and it would be great to get to the finals. If you get a medal, it's wonderful.
这就是每个运动员在职业生涯中都会经历不同事情的地方，压力的概念会在整个职业生涯中发生变化。你在团队中承担不同的责任。你知道，你只是替补席上的一员，突然你成了首发，现在你是队长，现在你是被期望扛起球队的人。你第一次参加奥运会，如果能进入决赛就太好了。如果你能拿到奖牌，那就太棒了。
Then somewhere in your career, you're going to your third Olympics, and if you don't get a medal, it's a failure. Oh, and actually, if you don't get a gold medal, you know, it'll be a bit of a failure. And so as your career changes, the expectations that are put on you or that you put on yourself change. A lot of your work now is focused on bringing out the best in children, whether it's in the classroom or sports. You're on APA's Coalition for Psychology of High Performance.
然后，在你的职业生涯中，你会参加第三次奥运会，如果你没有拿到奖牌，那就是失败。哦，实际上，如果你没有拿到金牌，你知道，那也会有点失败。因此，随着职业生涯的变化，施加在你身上或你自己施加给自己的期望也会发生变化。你现在的大部分工作都集中在挖掘孩子们的潜能上，无论是在课堂上还是在体育运动中。你是美国心理学会“高性能心理学联盟”的成员。
Can you explain what this group is doing? Psychologists are studying what makes some kids more successful in what they have found. I think the first part to answer that question is to kind of delve into the psychology of high performance a little bit to begin with. And for me, it goes back to that process of planning and preparing for an event. We're going to be judged, evaluated, held to a standard, which could be others or on your own, and then being able to get out and deliver what you've put in. And so there's a process of really understanding that performance context to make sure you're really focused on the right things.
你能解释一下这个小组在做什么吗？心理学家正在研究是什么让一些孩子更成功，他们发现了什么。我认为回答这个问题的第一部分是先深入探讨一下高性能心理学。对我来说，这回到了为事件进行规划和准备的过程。我们将被评判、评估、按照标准衡量，这可能是别人的标准，也可能是你自己的标准，然后能够走出去并交付你所投入的东西。因此，有一个真正理解该表现背景的过程，以确保你真正专注于正确的事情。
And there's some truth to the idea that great performance happened when you're not thinking, except that even when we're asleep, we're dreaming, our brains are always working. So it never really is the case that we're not thinking. We're thinking in a very qualitatively different way, and so you put that together into a plan to be able to do that. And yet I know no athlete that can really stick to that. that consistently. We're going to get distracted by something in performance, and usually the things that distract us most are things that are related to threat. It might be threat physically if you're
“伟大的表现发生在你没有思考的时候”这种说法有一定道理，但即使我们在睡觉时也在做梦，我们的大脑总是在工作。所以我们从不真正处于“不思考”的状态。我们是以一种质上不同的方式在思考，所以你把这些整合到一个计划中来做到这一点。然而，我知道没有哪个运动员能真正坚持做到这一点。我们会在表现中被某些事情分心，通常最让我们分心的事情是与威胁相关的事情。如果你在
competing in the brain. It might be threat to outcome in terms of the competition, the officials. And lots of times, the biggest threat to the thing that distracts us most is something that's a threat to our sense of self-worth and identity. And especially as you see athletes put more of their identity on things that they're doing and more expectations on themselves, they end up putting more pressure on themselves. They're their own worst enemies. Absolutely. And it happens in a very positive way initially, but sometimes we can just get unbalanced in our lives. And certainly within the world of track and field, there are athletes who judge themselves against others based on how they perform. If you run faster than me,
比赛中，这可能是身体上的威胁。这可能是比赛结果方面的威胁，比如裁判。很多时候，对最让我们分心的事情的最大威胁是威胁到我们的自我价值感和认同感。特别是当你看到运动员将更多的认同感放在他们所做的事情上，并对自己抱有更多期望时，他们最终会给自己施加更大的压力。他们是自己最大的敌人。绝对是。起初这以一种非常积极的方式发生，但有时我们的生活会失去平衡。当然，在田径界，有些运动员会根据自己的表现来评价自己与他人的差距。如果你跑得比我快，
you're a better person than me. And it would be easy for someone with a psychology training to come in and say, you know, that's just not true. You should see yourself differently, except in that environment, there are plenty of people who do judge others based on that. And the athletes see that. They know that. And so it's hard not to internalize that. And so from there, I think that general approach to managing pressure is something that kids, particularly today, face all over the place, pressure to get into college, not just college, the right college, pressure to do well on testing, pressure to do well in all of the things that go in their lives, whether it's interviews for college, interviews for jobs. And so I think helping them learn how to manage that is a wonderful
你就是比我更好的人。对于一个受过心理学训练的人来说，进来并说“你知道，那是不对的。你应该以不同的方式看待自己”是很容易的，但在那种环境中，有很多人确实根据表现来评价他人。运动员们看到了这一点。他们知道这一点。所以很难不将其内化。因此，我认为这种管理压力的通用方法是孩子们，尤其是今天的孩子们，在各处都面临的问题，比如进入大学的压力，不仅仅是大学，而是好的大学，考试取得好成绩的压力，在生活中所有事情上表现良好的压力，无论是大学面试还是工作面试。所以我认为帮助他们学习如何管理这些是一个很棒的
skill set, a wonderful mindset for them to develop. And I think my role is to take their interest in sport and use that as an opportunity to have discussions that they probably wouldn't engage in otherwise. And it's amazing how a lot of people in sports psychology have focused on interventions and not sort of this underlying psychological examination of what's going on to lead to pressure. And then there's a number of other areas that really have been exploring the psychology of high performance, but because we've normally thought of that with respect to sport, and they didn't work with athletes, you know, we just haven't made that connection that it really is more than just sport. It's performance settings across the board.
技能组合，一个很棒的心态。我认为我的角色是利用他们对体育的兴趣，将其作为讨论的机会，否则他们可能不会参与这些讨论。令人惊讶的是，许多运动心理学领域的人都专注于干预措施，而不是对导致压力的潜在心理进行检查。还有许多其他领域确实一直在探索高性能心理学，但因为我们通常认为这与体育有关，而他们不与运动员合作，你知道，我们只是没有建立起这种联系，即它确实不仅仅是体育。它是各行各业的表现环境。
And so this coalition is our initial attempt to really try and get different divisions, different people together, trying to talk about the things that are going, on in our area. And ultimately, our big project that we're working towards is to really clarify a psychological understanding of what needs to happen in performance settings and then work off of that to create a developmental model. So as kids are developing, you can have teachers in an academic studying, parents, coaches, understand here is some mental skills, mental characteristics that kids at this age level should learn, can learn, or in some cases are just not ready to learn yet. And if we can create that kind of heuristic and checklist for people, I think it
所以这个联盟是我们最初的尝试，旨在真正尝试将不同的部门、不同的人聚集在一起，试图谈论我们领域正在发生的事情。最终，我们正在努力实现的大项目是真正澄清在表现环境中需要发生什么的心理学理解，然后在此基础上建立一个发展模型。因此，随着孩子们的成长，你可以让学术环境中的老师、家长、教练了解在这个年龄段的孩子应该学习、可以学习，或者在某些情况下还没有准备好学习的心理技能和心理特征。如果我们能为人们创造那种启发式方法和清单，我认为
will really help bring an appreciation to this part of talented kids development. And I think that's our ultimate goal is to really help performance at the very highest range of what we as people are capable, and at the same time helping every person increase their performance, even if that maximum potential is, you know, just average. I think some of us have this idea that we're born mentally tough, too. or that we just need to focus and we'll succeed. But I think what you're saying is that's not always the case. There are other factors coming into play here when it comes to high performance. What sort of advice do you give to kids and their parents to help them face the pressures they face and still be successful?
它将真正有助于人们欣赏天才儿童发展的这一部分。我认为这是我们的最终目标，即真正帮助人们在人类能力所及的最高范围内表现，同时帮助每个人提高表现，即使这种最大潜力只是平均水平。我认为我们有些人认为我们天生心理素质就很强，或者我们只需要专注就能成功。但我认为你所说的是，情况并非总是如此。当涉及到高性能时，还有其他因素在起作用。你给孩子和家长什么建议来帮助他们面对压力并取得成功？
I think a big thing is trying to find a sense of balance and perspective in where sport and performance fits in their lives. It usually starts conversations with kids and trying to get parents involved in that. have worked with a number of athletes that because they are known as the golfer in high school, and that's where they're at, anytime something isn't perfect in golf, it's just scary and threatening, and at some point it's a lot easier to leave golf than to continue to live with that. I think having them try and get a good sense of what's really important in performance, so they really know what to focus on. It's amazing to me in London, at the games, talking to athletes that were,
我认为很重要的一点是试图在体育和表现如何融入他们的生活之间找到一种平衡感和视角。这通常始于与孩子的对话，并试图让家长参与其中。我曾与许多运动员合作过，因为他们被称为高中里的高尔夫球手，这就是他们的定位，任何时候高尔夫中出现不完美，都会让人感到害怕和威胁，在某种程度上，离开高尔夫比继续忍受那种生活要容易得多。我认为让他们试着对表现中真正重要的事情有一个很好的认识，这样他们才能真正知道该关注什么。在伦敦奥运会上，与那些
on journalists' lists of metal contenders didn't really have a very specific deliberate plan of what they should focus on while they were competing. If they came to the right thing, they were going to end up on the podium, and unfortunately for some of them, they were thinking about the wrong thing and didn't even get out of the first round.
在记者奖牌争夺者名单上的运动员交谈时，我感到很惊讶，他们并没有一个非常具体、刻意的计划来决定他们在比赛时应该关注什么。如果他们做对了，他们最终会登上领奖台，但不幸的是，对于他们中的一些人来说，他们想错了事情，甚至没能从第一轮中突围。
And so even at that level, they don't really have that clarified. It's really easy to say focus and pay attention, and I actually think a lot of athletes are really good at it. They're just really good at focusing on the wrong things. And I think some of the things that we need to focus on to learn and develop and practice are different from what we need to do. And that's where understanding motor learning, motor control comes into play to be able to put that together. So those
所以即使在那个水平上，他们也没有真正理清思路。说“专注”和“注意”很容易，而且我实际上认为很多运动员真的很擅长这一点。他们只是非常擅长关注错误的事情。我认为我们需要关注、学习、发展和练习的一些事情与我们需要做的事情是不同的。这就是理解运动学习和运动控制发挥作用的地方，以便能够将其整合在一起。所以这些
are the two big things that I start off with. And then we get into this process of really understanding those distractions. And I think a part of that comes back to an appreciation of psychophysiology, that in performance settings and there's a tremendous amount of emotion, there's a huge reaction in the body that comes with that emotion. And I think most psychologists conceptually get that. and most people understand the mind-body connection, but I don't think we really fully understand the interconnection and the pathways from heart and lungs in particular that go up not just to control centers,
是我开始时提到的两件大事。然后我们进入真正理解这些干扰的过程。我认为其中一部分归结为对心理生理学的欣赏，即在表现环境中存在大量的情绪，这种情绪伴随着身体的巨大反应。我认为大多数心理学家在概念上都理解这一点，大多数人都理解身心联系，但我认为我们并没有真正完全理解这种相互联系，特别是心脏和肺部的路径，它们不仅向上通向控制中心，
but to parts of the brain that are involved in responding to the environment, deciding valence what's important, what's not in the environment, so we can make decisions, we can analyze it, we can decide how we want to respond and then execute that. And if you have too much emotion and the wrong things going on in the body, it's going to interfere with that process. And so I think there's some people that focus on the idea of toughness of sort of ignoring emotion. And it's great, it's wonderful.
而且通向大脑中参与响应环境、决定效价（什么是重要的，什么在环境中不重要）的部分，这样我们就可以做出决定，我们可以分析它，我们可以决定我们想要如何响应，然后执行它。如果你有太多的情绪和身体中错误的事情发生，它会干扰这个过程。所以我认为有些人专注于“坚韧”的概念，即某种程度上忽略情绪。这很好，这很棒。
It doesn't affect them, except that there's still things going on internally in the brain. So they might not feel that emotion, and yet it still has an impact on their performance. And what happens a lot of times is they're able to perform well, but it comes at a tremendous cost in terms of energy and it's exhausting and it's unsustainable. It's not fun anymore. I think at some point it becomes just a burden as opposed to, you know, causing elation, I guess, at the end of the day. I've worked with many athletes that are incredibly mentally tough and yet they use that in a way where they're beating their head against the wall. You know, they're able to take more pain. They're able to suffer more than others. And so it's, I'm not sure it's the right concept for what we're ideally looking for. Switching gears a little bit, there are so many resources now at our fingertips, you know, in our phones and online.
它不会影响他们，除非大脑内部仍然在发生事情。所以他们可能感觉不到那种情绪，但它仍然对他们的表现产生影响。很多时候发生的情况是他们能够表现良好，但这付出了巨大的能量代价，而且令人筋疲力尽，是不可持续的。这不再有趣了。我认为在某种程度上，它最终变成了一种负担，而不是在一天结束时引起欢欣鼓舞。我曾与许多心理素质极强但却以一种“撞南墙”的方式使用这种素质的运动员合作过。你知道，他们能够承受更多的痛苦。他们能够比别人遭受更多的苦难。所以，我不确定这是否是我们理想中寻找的概念。稍微转换一下话题，现在我们触手可及的资源太多了，你知道，在我们的手机和网上。
How much is technology playing a role in the application of performance psychology? I know it's something that you've really been doing. I think we're just starting to see the advent of that and the integration of that. When you're talking about wearable devices, when you're looking at the integration of sport analytics in sports, looking mostly at statistics to begin with, but now as we can look at all of these devices that give us so much data, I think it's inevitable. In addition that most of the athletes growing up that are going to be professional athletes are wedded to technology. I think there's a part of technology that eventually is going to have to come out in necessity because that's what kids know. But I think it allows us to do so much more.
技术在表现心理学的应用中发挥了多大的作用？我知道这是你一直在做的事情。我认为我们才刚刚开始看到它的出现和整合。当你谈论可穿戴设备时，当你观察体育分析在体育中的整合时，主要是看统计数据，但现在我们可以查看所有这些提供如此多数据的数据设备，我认为这是不可避免的。此外，大多数成长为职业运动员的运动员都离不开技术。我认为技术的一部分最终必然会显现出来，因为那是孩子们所知道的。但我认为它让我们能够做更多的事情。
We can collect different kind of data. We can look at what they're doing. we can reach them at times that don't involve our office. I'm working on a project trying to get access to kids through online teaching, it will be a subset of what sports psychology can really do and it won't replace people, but for someone to have an economical access to this in their own home, instead of having to pay a lot of money to go talk to a stranger and the stigma that that might bring up, you know, sounds like a wonderful door opener.
我们可以收集不同种类的数据。我们可以观察他们在做什么。我们可以在不涉及办公室的情况下联系他们。我正在进行一个项目，试图通过在线教学接触孩子，这将是运动心理学真正能做的事情的一个子集，它不会取代人，但对于某人来说，在自己家里就能以经济实惠的方式获得这种服务，而不是花很多钱去和一个陌生人交谈，以及这可能带来的耻辱感，你知道，这听起来是一个很棒的敲门砖。
I have no doubt that we're going to have a lot of people who, put the cart before the horse, so to speak, that there's definitely going to be some things out there that are going to promise more than they can deliver. All right. Well, Dr. Patanga, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a real pleasure. It's been my pleasure, Audrey. Appreciate it. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the topics we discussed, or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingof psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我毫不怀疑，我们会有很多人“本末倒置”，可以说，肯定会有一些东西承诺的比它们能提供的更多。好的。好吧，波坦加博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这真是一次愉快的交谈。这是我的荣幸，奥黛丽。非常感谢。感谢收听。如果您想了解更多关于我们讨论的主题的信息，或者如果您想收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。